[Musik]
mir wurde gerade 99 Euro donated
ach du scheiße der ist für dich ich
dachte du bist vielleicht kurz weg und
dann wollte ich kurz töten
was soll denn die Scheiße warum schlägst
du mich denn immer du fängst doch immer
an mit deinem scheiß Stress das regt
mich schon wieder auf ey ich mache die
Rüstungen vorhin auch ich habe gar
keinen Stress angefangen du kommst
einfach an schläfst mir eine Rüstung
schon wieder halb kaputt nur wegen dir
meine Rüstung ist halt kaputt nur wegen
dir
hey das ist doch nicht wahr das ist doch
nicht wahr dass ich die einmal treffe
und sie ist tot
weißt du was ich mache Sandra was ich
habe es ja vorhin schon gesagt ich bin
ein bisschen k.o heute vom Training von
der Woche bis sie mir nicht schlafen wir
beobachten dich heute einfach mal
was machst du
[Musik]
ich bin glaube ich seit zwölf Monaten
nicht geflogen oder so
dieses Jahr noch gar nicht
[Musik]
ja doch erst dreieinhalb Monate
dreieinhalb
TK es ist April ja dreieinhalb Monate
bist du dumm Januar Februar März April
mit april haben wir also wie viel Monate
Januar Februar März
Sandra wir haben was ist der erste Monat
im Jahr Januar Januar was ist der zweite
Monat der Februar der dritte drei Monate
liebe Grüße Familie wie viele Tage haben
wir im April jetzt im vierten Monat
[Musik]
13 richtig das heißt Januar Februar März
und einen halben april also 3 1/2 ich
sehe es ganz anders
scheißegal wie du siehst das ist falsch
erstmal alles sichern hier weil ich weiß
dass ich in der Höhle wieder sterben
werde ohne reden wissen wir alle müssen
wir nicht drüber reden es wird so sein
also freut euch drüber
[Musik]
wenn ich sterbe
darf ich fünf Minuten nicht sagen
im Ernst ja ein riesiges Kuss und
Dankeschön an euch alle ihr müsst hier
nicht rein es haben ihr müsst nicht
supporten genauso wenig bei Sandra meine
ich ähm
[Musik]
das nicht weil es mir Spaß
Smiley mit freudentränklichkeit
also es abonniert mal rein ja
[Musik]
was ist am 30 Meter was komm mal ran an
30 Meter
what's
[Musik]
no no no no you
ausgeblichen Leute ganz kurz wir machen
jetzt den prank ich werde jetzt einen
Schneemann bauen okay Sandra läuft da
hinten ja Leute
aber auch schon ja in guten sieben Stück
also wirklich da hat man einfach Bock
auf Mallorca
ist so ich bin so krass in der Minecraft
der Welt gefangen was ist denn mit
meiner Cam hier
eigentlich
das immer doch nur wenige Minuten später
[Musik]
mein eigenes Produkt kommt jetzt diesen
Freitag
verstanden Leute was kannst du
eigentlich
[Musik]
die braucht man Beruf ja Leute ich habe
mein Villa Dollar komplett verloren
ja
Luca
warum habe ich Mister snowman in meinem
Haus
warum ist hier ein Schneemann
warum
vom Tanz der so
tja
was macht der denn hier
hallo
sondern nicht schlagen der tut doch gar
nicht
ja ich will schlafen ja was macht der
ach ich glaube oder
wenn der langläuft macht er das zu
Schnee ich glaube man kann aufstehen
nicht schlafen
[Musik]
aber lacht ich wieder hier rum hüpft
das leider nicht
also Kiro wenn ihr mir noch drei mal
vier mal schreibst dreimal nein dann
lösch meine Nummer
wir haben ein riesiges Problem
das sieht hier aus wie die Flamingo
Toilette Sandra
hä aber es sieht auch Loki süß aus mit
dem Schnee finde ich
wie schnell was
läuft der hier über die Fackeln und mach
dir keinen Schnee ja die Frage was
machen wir müssen das Moment oder
weiterleben bleiben oder nicht ja lass
einfach eine Umfrage gemacht Schneemann
leben lassen ja oder nein ihr könnt
abstimmen okay 95% sagen Schneemann
leben lassen ein kleiner Bruder fragt
mich gerade Sandra kannst du mir eine 10
€ Paysafe Karte kaufen ich lege dir das
Geld in dein Zimmer wäre lieb und wann
kommst du wer bist du bei Steam kaufen
das habe ich früher auch immer so
gemacht oder der will sich von der
Paysafecard Dings holen und die Fans bei
irgendwem noch nie auf der Plattform ich
war schon auf der Plattform
Atom zu gucken was kostenloses gibt ne
klar man schaut doch mal so ich bin auch
völlig lost für
Dings Geld auszugeben für plus 18 Sachen
weil das halt so
so Dings bekommst im Internet
kostenlos auch also ich habe jetzt Jan
Schneemann besonderes Haus gesetzt und
äh wir lassen den Kopf drauf weil wir
Sandra einfach sagen das ist jetzt ein
gefährlicher Schneemann oh mein Gott wie
gruselig was denn
das ist ein gefährlicher Schneemann
das ist gefährlicher Schneemann der
greift dich an
er stirbt in der Nacht vielleicht baut
ihm ein Schuss
hast du den gerade so schnell getötet ja
okay du bist krass kann ich theoretisch
mich in einen Boot setzen und Mitten
alleine ein Pferd auf asozial hinter mir
herziehen durch den Ozean ja geht okay
[Musik]